hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast pros and cons of
analgesic use during inhalation
anesthesia presented by Ignacio Alvarez
Gomez J Sikora XM diplomat ahmed
diplomat professor anesthesiologist of
university Complutense spain I'm Alexis
Corrales of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before I begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop down box
that appears on the screen well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen and follow
the process to obtain your credits
please join me in welcoming dr. dr. de
segura I will now turn the presentation
over to him okay thank you very much for
invitation for staying here with you and
we try to give you an overview of the
use of analgesics during MCC all during
the reparative period and try to focus
on the pros and cons on the use of this
analgesics so we will review the current
practice on properties I'll just use and
try to describe mainly focusing on this
analgesic effects the positive and the
negative efforts on analgesic action
we are using analgesics during research
with animals although they may produce
some interference with our our
scientific results however we all know
that withholding and logistics
in an animal that is likely to suffer
from pain may also produce negative
consequences usually some degree of
thoughtful physiological changes on the
animal that may also impair or modify
our results scientific results and this
negative consequence for the animal
well-being so these consequences which
besides suffering involve uncontrollable
source of variability so that means that
we may even with required more animals
to get the necessary salts or good
quality results so we always use on just
six signal or animal models every time
we respect animal suffering from pain
because of the procedure sorry Cal
procedure or whatever that might produce
pain we need to use analgesics however
at some points the requirement for
analgesics can be lowered that means
that the degree of pain suffered by
animal can be light or even moderate
then we might consider the use of
different analgesics however in other
instances researchers may consider to
use analgesics just even in the case
pain is unlikely to core and that might
be good there I think committee may
consider this to be a refinement
however we should consider that the
analgesic use may also produce some
negative responses or efforts why are
our logistics normally administered to
animals
there are several results for a one of
those may involve that researchers may
think that pain protects the damaged
area that analgesics may produce side
effects and also that may interfere with
the scientific results also because we
still don't know the most effective
doses to be given to a specific species
for example Roland's compared to dogs
and cats where there are much more
studies try to identify the best doses
for them and finally because there might
be some good rhetoric constraints for
example there are limitations on the use
of opioids potent opioids under legal
control so plea we may have a
researchers a lack of information
related to the best way to provide
energy to our animals so what about the
Parian static use of analgesics and say
an anesthetic because we may consider
the Jews of analgesics when no pain is
suspected for example because the
procedure is not painful so I mean our
Majestics might not be required although
they may reduce the dose of anesthetic
swimmy use as well for example is what
come on to Purdue sedation with occulus
such as methadone and they may reduce
the amount of anaesthetics we are using
thus reducing the adverse effects
produced by tiger doses of the ascetic
however we may consider at the same time
to avoid the use of these drugs simply
because we don't need analgesic at all
actually on the other side when paying
suspected for example for surgical
procedures they should block all of the
septic input they should significantly
reduce and aesthetic requirements and
they reduce
usually highly recommended or even
mandatory we will consider nociception
against pain nociception is the mirror
process of encoding note system way and
pain sensation is not necessarily
implied for example during anesthesia
pain on the other side requires
unconsciousness
sorry consciousness on the contrary not
ception can be produced during
anesthesia that is during
unconsciousness so we should probably
define until Inception as the way we are
using our just experienced is here and
many people will consider this as
providing interpretive allergies here so
positively we may require to use
analgesics and actually most of them
will provide hypokinesia we are
referring to hypothesis 6 as those
tracks producing a lower degree of pain
perception of pain sensation so
analgesia the total of sense of pain
perception is desirable but probably not
clinical septal why because high doses
after logistics may produce for
analgesic effects but at the high cost
of adverse effects so the idea the
clinical idea is to provide analgesia
just to chew pain is absent but
sometimes just tolerable by the animal
the overall treatment or pain management
involves prevention this administration
of analgesics before
pain is perceived for example before
surgery the selection of analgesics
together with the dose and the duration
of the drugs
and finally the assessment that the
drugs administrate are producing the
desirous analgesia or pain perception is
processed through different four
different processes
the first one is transduction where the
noxious stimuli are transferred to an
electrical signal then the signal is
transmitted by a first order neuron and
then transfer to the spinal cord can be
modulated by increasing or decreasing
the pain perception or the noxious
stimuli actually and then is finally
perceive by the cortex by the brain so
at every level of these four processes
we can use different drugs or we have
different targets so actually since many
substances and pathways are involved
similarly we should treat pain with
different drugs and different pathways
so clinically probably no single drag is
fully effective to produce on Jie Jie
when we are dealing with severe pain
such as that produced by surgery what
are the drugs we are using to promote
analgesia preparative Li usually we are
using non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs we are using also populates and we
usually combine them and finally local
anesthetics now these three group drugs
are considered the mainstay for
producing analgesia to animals and
people as well so we should combine all
of them we might consider other drugs as
well near grants to produce these
effects or increase the efforts produced
by these three groups of objects so
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
should provide analgesia for light to
moderate pain they may reduce
really induce disinformation and derived
pain but they do not really reduce or
little anesthetic requirements these
drugs are usually administered before
surgery because they may better prevent
inflammation while surgery is start or
being produced opioids provides indicia
for moderate to severe pain they do not
reduce sorry be surgically induced
information and your regulatory type
with little constraints for some of them
for example for morphine methadone or
fentanyl these racks are usually
provided before surgery just to cover
the interpretive period by providing
antinodes reception and then to provide
analgesia in the post-operative period
once the animal has recovered the
typical opioids we're using are divided
in three different groups the MU agonist
like morphine methadone fentanyl or with
fentanyl may provide the highest level
of fixing analgesic efficacy
however they are highly control and at
some institutions you're difficult to be
achieve or used partial agonists like
buprenorphine may provide a lower degree
of analgesic efficacy although higher
compared to other logistics and finally
agonist antagonist Slyke litter for now
pre produce the lowest level of
analgesic action among the different
objects we are using clinically local
anesthetics are the only drugs that may
produce or may fall in blackness
deceptive input so they are an excellent
option to be combined with the previous
drugs they reduce on static requirements
Oh simply because they are blocking or
deceptive
input however we must be sure that the
application of the tracks are
appropriate so there's no such messes up
to the input or to the spinal cord to
the brain another advantage is that it
can be easily applied for example at the
bone side there might be [ __ ] Mamie
actually other methods to control pain
or manage pain actually there are many
peripherally or centrally mediated
substances that may promote analgesia
physiologically and also from a thematic
point of view so probably in the next
few years we will run we will find many
other type of drugs that may produce
adequate analgesia to our animals now we
try to identify the interaction that
might happen between the use of
different a logistics together with
anesthetics so since in relational in
stayshia is the main way to produce
anesthesia of course you can use
injectable incision and opiates may also
or other a logistics may also produce or
maple dictate the other artistic effort
so most of the rodents elicit eyes are
probably done with the use of isoprene
or silver frame and to identify the
interference between analgesics and
emulation or aesthetics we use normally
the minimal blood concentration on the
Mac as a surrogate or as an index of
inhalational and setting in additional
potency so we all know that the molar
concentration in the rat or in mice of
ice frame is 1.3 or around 1.3 however
we should keep in mind that every
individual will have its own
albero concentration so we should give
son oh gee no variability of
provide some pro viability on the
potency of these tracks into the
different individuals at the same time
the Mac is really a function of gnosis
active sensitivity to the stimulus
itself when we test or we determine the
minimum very concentration we're
actually applying an assertive
distinguish the stimulus so many heights
of rain or civil frames and ctvt genes
will also be necessary to sensitivity
genes as well anyway despite the
stability of the Mac because the
departed C of eyes of rain or soup of
rain with it a given species is
relatively a stable or not too variable
actually convert to for example
injectable aesthetics however we should
keep in mind that different strains may
give may behave differently when we
combine them drugs such as operates with
anesthetics in relational aesthetics
then we may respect a reduction in the
requirement of anesthetics to maintain
the same level of anesthesia and
typically the reduction that we might
consider clinically acceptable will be
between 30 and 70 percent fully about 70
percents to match and we may find some
drawbacks or some adverse effects
derived from high doses of opioids such
as respiratory or cardiovascular
depression so we should balance the
amount of opiates who are given to
animal together with amount of
inhalation on aesthetics were given just
to ensure adequate level of anesthesia
analgesia
and at the same time to maintain
physiological variables as physiological
as possible
so typically we use different or studies
with
experimental design we all provide a
brain or sort of rein to an animal like
rat and then we determine the molar
concentration for that individual animal
and then we give the opioid then once we
give the opiate we may expect reduction
in the mineral BR concentration and at
the same time but we teach in the magnet
recreation several times we may also
find the duration of the effort then
opioids consistently reduce an aesthetic
requirements bad for example
nonsteroidals do not reliably reduce or
just slightly reduce the unsteady
requirements however it's interesting to
notice that the combination of Achatz
together with non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs may provide some
some your gistic or additive efforts
that means that the final reduction in
unstable requirements is haider local
anesthetics can also reduce anesthetic
requirements and those can be used as
unofficial or can be given a dual side
so cut in reducing masses active stimuli
this slide shows the typical dose
response relationship between for
example morphine on top and again static
requirements of ice frame so for example
one milligram per kilo may reduce 20%
and aesthetic requirements while three
milligrams per kilo may reduce close to
30% and then 50% when 10 milligrams per
kilo are provided to a rat in another
study we found that we may achieve up to
80 percent reduction in Incivek
requirements and these results are quite
consistent if we look to the figure on
the bottom of the slide then different
opiates like sufentanil fentanyl when
fentanyl or fentanyl have been used in
order to reduce anesthetic requirements
and gain we may find
slight reductions below 25% up to 90%
reduction in ISO for an or several
ranges these two studies or together
from our lab so we see are those related
response so for example will be profane
may produce from 10 to 20% reduction
with only 10 microns per kilo up to 50
to 55 more or less reduction when 100
micrograms per kilo are used so by
selecting appropriately the different
doses of the different tracks we may
find which is the dose range with Gmail
which reduce to reduce anesthetic
requirements and Perley to produce more
analgesia to our animals this is a final
slide where most known opioids use in
the clinical setting or laboratory
setting including for example wheat or
phenol if you know fame together with
fentanyl or any fentanyl morphine
also methadone or tramadol they all can
be produced reduction in aesthetic
requirements and when properly selected
you may find that when low doses are
considered they may produce a reduction
in study requirements between 25 for 50
percent and then if you want to select
the high girl those range then you may
provide 50 up to 100 which is
ception up 100 reduction in aesthetic
requirements when for example methadone
has been used it recently if you use
methadone up 10 milligrams per kilo for
example and you compare this those with
1 5 milligrams per kilo you may notice
that there's not any further reduction
in aesthetic requirements so that means
that drugs like the tofranil probably
will not provide any further advantage
by increasing the dose from fentanyl is
probably the most use opioid currently
in the human setting it is used also in
the veterinary setting and may provide
good steady and Letizia
however the problem with fentanyl is
that you should use an infusion o
because the action of the drug in judge
accidents may last only 4 to 5 minutes
so this is an advantage on one side
because we may adjust the level of
analgesia at every time point of cidery
of the procedure but on the other side
once the diffusion has been stopped
analgesia disappears so the animal
should be covered with other products on
Jessup tracks again there are
variability there is a variability in
the efforts of heights of rain depending
on the strain so this is a typical
demonstration on how different strains
of mice for example may require
different doses of anaesthetics and then
on top of that you may use analgesics to
further reduce the amount of anesthetics
you may require for your procedure
another interesting or useful
considering the use of opioids or
analgesics in general is that every time
we are using logistic we may spec SPECT
the define effort for example give
Ingram fentanyl of 120 micrograms per
Gregoire may reduce the cellophane
requirements by 20% some of some animals
here we sold some clothes to I think 180
rats or individuals some of them may
have a higher effort so the reduction
may be up to 40 or close to 50% however
a more interest wave on the other side
on the left side you may see that some
animals may have a quite a different
response that means that even given
Graeme French mail they may require even
more love rain to maintain the desired
level of anesthesia so not always we are
going to find a good effort of
analgesics we always aim to produce on
Jie Jie when our analysis our provider
that's for sure that's obvious however
analgesic administration does not
guarantee adequate analgesia so we
always must ensure our assess that the
analgesic effort has been produced to
our animals and finally I would like to
sell you another efforts recently found
o and derived from the use of mainly of
opioids usually opioids may produce
behavioral efforts may produce
respiratory depression especially in the
human being on cardiovascular depression
so for example bradycardia and some
point hypotension may appear after a
dose of for example fentanyl or method
on however recently there is more
evidence telling us that there are also
unwanted energetic efforts first because
of the reduce efficacy of the drugs
mainly by chronic administration for
example giving morphine to a patient
with cancer may lv8
pain but with time the pace
may require more and more doses or
higher doses of morphine to prevent pain
to a core but on the other side and
logistics may also increase pain and
this is paradoxical because we are
always expecting that an opioid may
reduce pain but not increase it so how
is that it is well known that opiates
may induce tolerance but also
hyperalgesia tolerance can be defined
for Marga logic responds normally
following repeat or prone or prolonged
of the administration that is decrease
or the deal and Jessica Fett has been
decreased and the pain thresholds are
typically not modified the reason for
that can be that receptors are
internalized so they are not available
for the effect of the drugs
however when higher doses of opioids are
given then you may increase the Majestic
effort however on the other side operate
may induce also hyperalgesia we shall
remember that we are respecting hypo GCR
analgesia so this is the opposite effort
hyperalgesia has been defined as
increased pain from the stimulus that
normally provokes pain and pain
thresholds are typically reduce so the
effort is double an opiate may produce
analgesia or hyperalgesia on one side
and may also produce hyperalgesia
however why we are reducing this racks
because we are using them because they
produce hydrogen or lgz
and that's because hyperalgesia
typically may appear after the analgesic
effort so this is one of our results we
found some years ago when we were
working on the use of rain fentanyl in
rats so we gave one hundred and twenty
micrograms per kilo per hour and these
those produce reductions something
around 25 30 percent and then we gave
242 for the dose of remi fentanyl and it
actually produced a reduction close to
40 to 50 percent and since we are given
an infusion we might expect to keep this
level of anesthetic aspiring effort for
the time we are providing the energetic
but surprisingly what we found was that
actually one hour and a half later the
reduction immensity requirements were
only one-half despite the levels in
blood of remphan toenail remain steady
or constant so when we stop the
administration of the drug then what was
suspected was that the levels or the
potency of the anesthetic I'll regain
baseline balance so we were a little bit
I'll impress not because a majestic
oculus specifically we're producing
tolerance for hyperalgesia but because
it was produce only one hour or one hour
and a half the start of the
administration of the drug so that means
that you may find that the frequency of
the track may be limited just or even
during the perioperative period so first
we start by increasing the dose of brain
fentanyl and in a similar study then we
increase from 120 here you see the
baseline on the left side then the
maximum effort of the drag bring the
fentanyl and then the reduce effort 100
hours ago
then we increase the dose we doubled
those to 240 mm microns per kilo per
hour for my fentanyl and again we reduce
them set of requirements but again one
hour and a half later the values were
similar to those previously same and one
half or more those suspected initially
so that means that these drugs opioids
are not so efficacious in the medium or
short term similar studies for example a
song that demonstration of methadone at
different doses may produce hyperalgesia
in this case they use the tail flick
test in conscious animals in contrast to
the previous study in the anesthetized
animals and we can see in female rats on
the lab for male rats that there's a
reduction or actually there's
hyperalgesia an effort of hyperalgesia
those related in all animals so the idea
oh is that probably when you give a drug
you are producing hyperalgesia and this
is the blue box this hyperalgesia has a
reducing effort with time and then once
you stop giving a logistics hurry
there's a hyperalgesia effort that may
last longer actually so let's say in
other way so this is the antiseptic on
time acceptable on the left side on top
perceptive effort below then we are
given an opioid and the opioid should
provide analgesic effort so that will
mean to provide some level of antinos
reception but this effort is reduced
with time then once we stop the opioid
concentrate of infusion
[Music]
then there's a hyper jzuk effort and
this effort we all know sorry we know
may last between three and four weeks in
for example rodents and rats
so probably our hypothesis is that every
time we are providing and appeared we
are given an opiate to an animal we are
producing at the same time and hippo
hype artistic effort together with a
hydrologic effort and balance between
both will determine if we are finally
finding analgesia or hyperalgesia so
since there is an interaction between
opioids on inhalation aesthetic and
since we saw this this high producing
ethanol opiates we hypothesize also that
the Mac might be increased just by given
an opiate before anesthesia and when I
mean before I mean at least one day
before not just a few always before a
few minutes so we were able to
demonstrate that the administration of
opioids in the first incision may
produce a reduction in the effectivity
of this anesthetic in sacrament seizure
done one week later the effort is
--slide no more than 20% but it can be
evidence in this studies so this two
reports from our lab as well so the D
effective may last up to 28 days for
example on top in the figure on top we
see the administration of rain fentanyl
is producing a reduction in the effort
or in the potency of the immolation
anesthetic so the Mac is increased and
in the lower figure we see how the
different drugs Weprin often method on
morphine Remi fentanyl or criminal
now the control on the left side may
produce an increase in the Mac value
when ii mac determination was performed
one week later so it seems the efforts
are not related just only to where my
fentanyl
but also to many other opiates we might
consider even those that might be
considered to be less potent and finally
recently we look to non opiate drugs in
this case we decide to study an interest
in drag which is methimazole this drug
is not used in the United States or
Canada however is quite popular in Spain
France or Germany as far as I know well
mainly because in contrast to
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
vitamins Allah does not produce good and
confirmatory action but at the same time
does not produce Oh significance side or
there's adverse effects so is popular in
the para periodic period then we test
this track together with all morphine
and we compare we gave these two drugs
to rats and several days two days and
four days later we found that and the
hyperalgesia was present and similarly
so for example when we test with the
bone pride test
I'm applying or testing mechanical
thresholds we saw that both drugs
produce a similar level of hyperalgesia
and quite similar when you consider in
on the bottom of the of the slide did
you consider the thermal blong test so
so we give analgesics when required
considering that analgesics may produce
at the same time the opposite effort at
least when opioids are considered
I don't think we should stop giving
opiates because this racks are probably
the best way to produce gluten GCR to
treat civil pain oh the true prevalence
of these side effects are Utley are
still unclear and probably if you
consider other drugs like local
anesthetics they are likely to produce
these habits although we didn't test
these drugs in our studies so what are
the potential finally strategies for the
Prevention of hyperalgesia
or tolerance so plea these are first
voluntary the onset ik effect of the of
the isoprene or sip of rain that is not
reducing the Mac and second bite prevent
inhibit hyperalgesia so for example in
Rowley study some twenty years ago more
or less we consider the use of the gold
standard of popu it's morphing together
with the gold standard of hunting for
matauri agents like aspirin
acetaminophen now sorry Osprey in this
case not acetaminophen and then we found
that one milligram per kilo of morphine
produce reduction of 20% that may be
increased to nearly 30% with three
milligrams per kilo or between 650 and
16% with 10 milligrams per kilo so is it
clear those related response however
when we gave us praying together with
morphine one ms one per kilo the effect
was similar to that produced by 3
milligrams per kilo of morphine so we
might consider to reduce the dose of the
insetting but also the dose of the
opioid given the same might happen when
four milligrams per kilo morphine were
combined with a spring and this efforts
have been demonstrated in other or with
other non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs and
other energetic tracks like personal in
this case it's acetaminophen so for
example we use ketoprofen pericope save
and gain another drag not consider to be
inflammatory dragged appear on or
methimazole these are two names we use
for these drugs
Percy d'amour is an interesting drag and
we've seen that it may potentate the
effects of opioids like when fentanyl
aid for example and it's interesting
right because it may not have or
actually does not have an telemetry
effects so might be convenient for those
studies where I'm not inflammatory
effect is not desired for example
methimazole has we already so may
potentate as well DF itself Remi
fentanyl so it's an interesting drug to
be given fairly not to be used in places
like the United States or Canada where
it's not available
another drive we can do this is getting
ketamine is quite commonly used drugs to
produce anesthesia in rodents and
actually it may pollinating those
related oil fashion the effects of remi
fentanyl for example so you might
consider to give a small dose of
ketamine to produce this increase effort
another interesting Brad is gabapentin
gabapentin also can produce an
enhancement in the reduction of the map
so it's an interesting drag to be
provided in some procedures other drugs
such as
amitriptyline - Italy Norma repeat and
may produce also a decrease in the
anesthetic requirements
finally another way to contour it
hyperalgesia can be to prevent or heave
it
this phenomenon so for example we
consider the use of drugs such as ultra
low doses of naloxone for example or the
intelligence of the tlr4 this is a non
opioid receptor and there and the
rationale for this is that it is thought
that opiates may not only induce
activation of the opioid receptor but
also the TLR till our 4 receptor and
when this receptor is activated it may
produce pro-inflammatory responses so
again when using neutral doses of
naloxone we were able to block the hyper
jessic effort of the drag but not
interestingly not blocking the analgesic
effect of the opioid only the
hyperalgesia and gain when we were given
o populates when fentanyl for example in
this case to knockout mice of knock out
for a tlr4 o receptor we were able to
block the hyperalgesia produced by Ramy
fentanyl so to finish we may consider
still consider the obvious remain the
most potent a logistics we may found to
be used for the treatment of pain but we
should also consider that they also may
promote anti energetic options however
the clinical relevance is still to be
determined
probably the combination of opioids
together with other analgesic drugs like
usually like non-story inflammatory
drugs local anesthetics may promote a
better knowledge
yeah and probably reduce the side fsd
analgesic side effects observe with
opiates we do use a populates poly for
known overall painful procedures might
not be considered a way we still need
foreign studies to determine that but
very non-story those may suffice for
that and remember always every time
you're producing a pain free procedure
you may consider you might consider now
you may consider sorry the use of
opiates nonsteroidal and local
anesthetics may be together with other
cracks such as cadmium but probably this
drugs are less effective or few studies
are known to - you know conserve the
true butter till - efficacy of districts
thank you very much let's get started
our first question is are opiates the
only effective means to manage very
painful procedures such as surgery
opiates are the main staying the
mainstay for producing energy CL for
severe pain and prey we should still use
them on a routine basis however we
should always consider the use of other
cracks to produce analgesia for example
the use of local anesthetics may produce
a really good protein and Letizia to
manage this very paper procedures our
next question is opioid side-effects
irrelevant oh we still don't know how we
we consider that opioids produce a
really good analgesic effort important
energetic efforts but while we were
using then or we were using these drugs
over the last decades we found that
there's some side effects
that we might consider pray the the main
concern will be the use of opioids when
actually pain is not present in our
animals and we might consider then the
use of other drugs such as non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs probably the
relevancy of this side efforts L is not
hide anyway our next question is does
the combination of opioids with other
analgesics provide any advantage
oh definitely with all we should always
consider the use of opiates together
with nonsteroidals Oh for most
procedures where pain is likely to core
and when surgery is produced local
anesthetics are or should probably use
as well and it looks like we have time
for one more question should opioids be
employed in every potentially painful
procedure oh I still wish we should use
opiates in every potentially pain
superhero specifically in severe or for
severe pain I don't think we are still
able to stop using opiates to create
this you know severe pain I would like
to once again thank dr. Viktor goda
for his presentation I would also like
to thank Leopards
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye